well i think those words okay enough is
enough for words that uh many many
people in greater manchester
are using right now i've been going
around this weekend i was at a homeless
charity yesterday people are scared
people are genuinely scared about what's
coming
and when they look around they they
don't see how things are fair you know
they kind of see the cost of the
essentials water gas electric buses
trains you know guns gone through the
roof they see the bosses of those
companies getting massive payouts
and the workers people who work within
those organizations haven't got enough
to live on i think people are starting
to question
a lot basically of how things have been
organized in this country in recent
years and they want change i think the
public are ahead of the politicians
actually that they're ahead of it in
terms of seeing the scale of the cost of
living crisis but also the change that's
needed if we're to get get through it
fairly and that's what tonight's rally
is about i'll be pleased to welcome it
to manchester because you know from my
point of view i start with the residents
of greater manchester they are looking
for people to speak up for them and to
call for the big change that's needed
and that's what they're hearing from the
enough is enough campaign
who do you expect to attend
lots of people are coming actually all
walks of life i think it's something
that
is capturing the sort of moment um as i
say we need uh people to to wake up to
the scale of this and i think that's the
call will be going out from from tonight
um and you know i i would say to to all
my colleagues in west westminster my old
colleagues i think we need to start
approaching the cost of living crisis
like we did the early stages of the
pandemic
where the parties came together and
started to think of interventions that
perhaps they wouldn't think of in normal
times where key workers were
recognized and properly respected and
rewarded you know i heard a conservative
mp mr gullis on the media of the weekend
demonizing greedy rail workers in his
words well i'm sorry but that is just
not good enough these are the people
that he was clapping that everyone was
clapping a few years ago you know we
need to to recognize that people are
going to need fair pay rises if they're
going to keep britain running through
what is going to be a really challenging
time
um you are of course happy to share the
stage with the union leader mick lynch
would you be happy to share a picket
line with him
i would and you know i don't see this as
you know controversial you know people
are fighting for their incomes
in a cost of living crisis
and so of course you've got to
kind of recognize
the point that they are making they're
going to work but they don't have enough
to live on
and in calling for the party to approach
this like the pandemic i would say
particularly
to the government and if it is to be liz
truss who's the next prime minister
get round the table we've had a summer
of you know politicking really you know
making the unions responsible for
everything and you know kind of
all kinds of unhelpful rhetoric
you need to get around the table and
there needs to be sector by sector deals
here that are fair to people but also
keep the country running and if people
ask how that's to be paid for what i
would say okay is
we need now to open up a debate on the
culture of high and excessive pay in the
top half of organizations this has gone
on and on and on over the last couple of
decades where the gap between those at
the bottom and those at the top has just
got bigger and bigger there was research
last week that says in the ftse 100
companies on average the pay of those at
the top is 109
times higher than the pay of those at
the bottom i mean that is why people are
saying enough is enough
what about um energy companies and
energy bosses should energy companies in
the uk be private um
nationalize for now take it back into uh
public ownership well there's certainly
a case for more public control more
public ownership of essential utilities
you know i i've listened to the
leadership debate in the tory party this
summer and they've both been promising
more facturism well as far as i'm
concerned that is what got us into the
mess that we're in right now when we
sold off the water sold off the
electricity sold off the gas sold off
the council homes sold off the buses
sold up the trains we found ourselves in
a position where ordinary people can't
afford those basics anymore those
essentials and therefore change is
needed in the way that we provide those
essential services everybody needs the
basics everybody needs to be able to
afford the basics and this just isn't
okay i've taken the decision to put
buses back under public control in
greater manchester after 36 years of
deregulation on monday this coming
monday we will introduce a fair cap in
greater manchester a cap of two pound on
a single adult fare so we are taking
steps to that we can you know the talk
that i've heard this summer of more
deregulation more privatization that has
left us in a position where we've had
chaos on our trains buses that people
can't afford and raw sewage on our
beaches and that is why change is needed
two policies there that um you uh
completely opposite to what kiyostama
has suggested uh people on um
politicians on the picket lines and then
also uh the nationalization of the
energy companies you see the right man
for the job
i i didn't hear that question i'm sorry
you froze on me there no no no i'm very
sorry i'll i'll say it again tuesday
morning just having my first cup of tea
um and you know what northerners like
with their tea i was making the point
that um you've two two policies there
that are directly opposite to what we've
heard from sakiasdama one of them is
about politicians being on the picket
lines he doesn't think that's a good
idea senior politicians which of course
you are and the second one is um
nationalizing energy companies initially
we heard labour thought that was a good
idea and now they seem to have
backtracked is he the right man for the
job was the question
yes he is
and
i think what you can see is the support
for him in the polls is making that that
clear he did intervene in the summer uh
with the policy of a of a price uh
freeze and that is a very good start i
would say there is a there is a case to
go further as i've said this morning
in terms of you you said i've i'm saying
different things well i'm in a different
job i'm not in westminster decay i've
just got a role to speak up for greater
manchester that's different to any
politician in westminster so i will come
to different judgments as i look at it
right now
when i listen to people in grace monster
who tell me they're scared about what's
coming who tell me that already they've
turned every appliance off in their home
and they're they're cooking via their
microwave and nothing else
it's my job to respond to what they're
saying and actually then put forward
policies i think will support them there
is strong public support of what the
enough is enough campaign is saying on
all of the policies that there that
they're putting forward and it's my job
if you like from the outside to speak up
for the residents of greater manchester
everyone always thinks that whenever you
do anything it's an internal political
game well it's not i think we're beyond
any kind of time for those kind of those
kind of things this is a massive crisis
the scale of which we've not faced
before it will require politicians to do
different things to intervene in markets
to protect people and it's really
important that i use my voice to to say
that and hopefully give people
the space to come forward
and work out plans that will get the
country through this
do you support people joining don't pay
uk
well
this stage is definitely a step that i
wouldn't support you know we've got to
live within the rule of law haven't we
we've got to um keep a country where um
you know people respect um the the norms
and respect the way of doing things i
understand why people are saying it but
i wouldn't in any way
recommend that that's that's the way
that people people should go what we
need is
action to make things affordable for
people
but i do feel
that kind of call will increase unless
we see the scale of action that is going
to be going to be needed
uh paul franks has emailed me this
morning just before i let you go this
morning kay can you ask andy burnham
would he consider running for leader of
the labour party then ultimately prime
minister regards paul
i
have said one day if that were ever uh
something that that
would be something people would support
but not now
because um we've got a leader of the
labour party who is providing leadership
in the cost of living crisis and i'm
happy uh to give my full support to care
and i've got a job to do in greater
manchester okay you know i am making big
changes to public transport which
hopefully will help people
through this uh and that's where my full
focus is right now
but you're not ruling it out there are
you
well i've just been honest i i mean in
the future you know i've got i've said
i'll serve a full second term as mayor
of base manchester if at some point
beyond way beyond at this point where we
are that that was something that was a
possibility i would consider it but i'm
just focused on what i'm doing right now
we're putting in place a whole range of
support to help people through this
through this crisis that should be the
sole focus of politicians right now i
think
the people who are vying to be leader of
the tory party the ones that need to be
answering questions right now you know
they've spent the summer i think in a
comfort zone talking to their own party
giving them the kind of answers they
want to hear but actually those are the
things that got us into this mess in the
first place and i think if it is to be
liz trust she will need to make some big
big changes and big moves very quickly
if she's she is to come into this role
and help the country through this so
it's not about the future now is it it's
about today and who's going to give
people the reassurance that they're
looking for